[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN TREYNOR SLOSS:
So metrics that matter.
The remit for this talk was
basically, all right, fine,
you know you're in charge of--
oh, I should introduce myself.
So my name is Ben, and if
Google ever stops working,
it's my fault. I
forgot that part.
We did the intro in
the last session,
and I was running with that.
More concretely, I created the
Site Reliability team at Google
and still run it.
I also run all of
networking for Google
and all of data centers
for Google from design
and construction to operation.
So it's a low-stress
job, regular hours.
And it teaches you a
thing or two about scale.
And my background is
software engineering.
So this is sort of the first
operationally oriented gig I've
ever done in my entire career.
It's been an interesting
learning experience,
but I have learned a
few things about scale.
And one of the
things that I've seen
is sort of the pattern,
over and over again,
of the same small
number of metrics
show up time after time
in operating and measuring
and assessing software
services that are running
at a decent-sized scale.
And so rather than having a
generic talk about metrics
and why they're
important, blah blah blah,
you already know that, right?
Skip all that.
Let me tell you the three that
I've seen over and over again
actually are really
important, if you
want to have a great
user experience
at the end of the
day and you don't
want to have your service
collapse under its own weight.
So I've been doing
this since 2003.
Back then we still
had a cloud product.
We didn't call it
cloud at the time.
We called it Borg, but
it was all of the things
that you're now familiar with
in the public cloud offering.
We had services.
They run in containers.
You have these relatively
homogeneous and entirely
fungible compute platforms
that you run it on.
And jobs can move around
and things can die and blah
blah blah blah blah.
And it was a good
way to run Search,
and it turned out to be
a good way to run Gmail,
and we've kind of run with it.
And now, of course,
it's something
that we're offering to
everyone, and the term cloud
has picked up.
But we've been doing
this for a while.
And in particular, when
I went back and looked
at the scale of what
Google's been doing,
we've been through seven
orders of magnitude
so far and still growing.
So who knows?
In a couple of years
this presentation
may read differently.
But we have managed
over that time
to evolve some best practices
about how you run things
and also how you measure things.
We're going to skip how you run
things for a separate topic.
This is just about measuring.
And again, I want to note
this is not everything
that's important to measure.
These are the things
that I've found really
are both critical and
often not actually measured
because they're not
easy to measure.
But in retrospect, after
the bad user experience
or after the outage or
whatever, you sort of
go back and say,
wow, if only we had--
This is the "if
only we had" list.
So item number one--
measure your actual
user experience.
Seems straightforward, right?
You've all put your time
and effort and sweat equity
into building this service,
and you test it yourself.
If you're pretty much
like everybody out there,
your development team
uses your own product.
Otherwise, they wouldn't
be working in your company.
But you're testing it here or
in your development lab, close
to your servers, on a
really great network
with fairly little competition
and probably Wi-Fi backup.
So, newsflash--
most of the world
does not experience
your product the way
you are experiencing
your product.
In fact, statistically speaking,
very little of your user base
experiences it that way.
So rule number one
that we've come up with
is measure the actual
user experience, right?
Because your users
don't care how well it
works on your awesome brand
new Pixel on your Wi-Fi
in your home office
with your data
center 20 milliseconds away.
They care how it works for them.
And if it doesn't
work well for them,
somebody else will build
a product that does.
I know the answer.
But hang on.
But it's hard.
I apologize.
I'm going to move this thing.
It's hard to measure the
actual user experience.
It's much easier to
measure telemetry that's
coming back to our
servers or to measure
what we see in our test lab.
I apologize-- speaking of
measuring the actual user
experience.
[LAUGHTER]
It's my first time
with a headset,
and I think it's not
entirely agreeing with me.
So why do most
teams not actually
measure what their
users are experiencing?
Well, because you can't
exactly talk to your user base
into putting a GoPro behind
their head every time
they're using your product so
you can see what's going on.
It turns out that has a
very low adoption rate.
And it's not actually easy
to measure, especially
a mobile experience
or, in particular,
a web browser experience.
Back when everything
was thick client,
you could kind of instrument
your thick client,
and you'd have a
decent sense of what
the user experience was like.
But when you have all sorts
of other layers of software
in between your app and
what the user is doing,
and then you also
have a network,
and maybe you have a browser,
et cetera, et cetera,
it gets much harder.
And so, as a practical
matter, what I see often
is that teams
approximate this, right?
They'll put in some decent
server-side monitoring.
They may even have
a test lab where
they get some benchmark
results, like how long does
a page take to load and so on.
But they aren't actually
measuring the distribution
of what the user experience
is because it's difficult.
My advice for all of you?
Yes, it's hard.
Get through that
denial and get on
to actually measuring the thing.
And if you have to spend 10% of
your engineering team to do it,
do it.
Because that is what your
user experience is, and you're
spending the other 90%
trying to write a software
service or a feature
or a cool widget,
and you have no idea
what people actually see
when they try to use it, right?
So it's the number one omission.
What can I say?
Even at Google, we pretty
regularly run into this.
The team presents, here's what
they think the service is like.
And then you actually go
and do tours, for example,
and you look.
And the experience
is totally different.
We see it over and over again.
I see it when I
talk to companies
that are building products
both on Cloud and not on Cloud.
They really only approximate
what the user experience is.
And why is this important?
Well, let me give you a case
study from Google's history.
Ah-- defense in depth--
very important concept
in reliability.
We're not going to
talk about it today.
But you just had it illustrated.
So back in 2004, Google
launched this service.
Some of you may
have heard of it.
It's called Gmail.
It promised at the time
a gigabyte of storage.
Ooh, ah!
Back at the time,
that was impressive.
I think you got 5
megabytes on some
of the other popular services.
And people's use of it was
almost entirely browser-based.
There was mobile adoption, but
it was not the dominant way
of accessing Gmail.
And so the teams did what
pretty much everybody did, which
is well, let's look at what's
happening at the server, right?
And if we get the HTTP request,
and we send the response,
and it took us 220
milliseconds on average
to server the response, and we
had an error rate of whatever,
0.007%, life is good.
So that went on for a while.
We got anecdotal reports
of people saying,
well, you know Gmail is
slow, and the experience
is not really that great,
especially if I'm not
connected to really fast 2
megahertz Wi-Fi, et cetera, et
cetera.
And so eventually we decided
to launch a new Gmail client.
It's JavaScript that
actually got downloaded
when you started using Gmail.
And we decided to
instrument the client.
And then we had the
five stages of grief--
starting with, as it
always does, denial, right?
No, no, no, this can't
possibly be right.
There's no way it's taking
20 seconds to load the inbox,
because when I do it here
at Google on my brand new--
oh god, at the time, who knows--
Intel laptop running Firefox,
it's nice and snappy, right?
Well, I don't need to spell
the rest of it out for you.
That is not the
normal experience.
And in fact, the
inbox load times
were very, very, very slow.
The mail message load
times were very slow.
In some cases, the page
render times were very slow.
You had to get through denial.
So after a couple of rounds of
making sure the metrics were
right and actually doing
tests out in the field,
we convinced ourselves,
OK, actually no, this
is what the user experience is.
Wow, that's pretty crappy.
And we got eventually to
bargaining, which basically
became a whole new
set of changes,
both interestingly changes
on the server side, things
like delivering
incremental updates
and delivering
real-time time feed,
and obviously on
the client side,
where you make rendering
changes and you
change sort of how the page
is presented and so on.
You actually might
present it differently
on a different-speed
device so that you
don't consume too much of your
time just trying to literally
draw the pixels on the screen.
And I remember distinctly--
this was 2006-ish, there
was this inflection.
Gmail had been
growing beautifully.
It had an
up-and-to-the-right curve,
which I will now
illustrate in the air.
And then we launched
the new client,
and then its curve did that.
And it was this--
you could correlate
this change in
the adoption curve
to us launching the new client
and the server updates that
were entirely due to having
actually measured the user
experience and getting through
the five stages of grief.
It was a significant effort.
There was a lot of debate at the
time about, is this important?
And shouldn't we be adding
a bunch of new features?
And look at Hotmail and look
at Yahoo Mail and et cetera.
But we spent the effort
to improve the client
and to improve the user
experience for people
who didn't have
the latest laptop
and didn't have the really
fast Wi-Fi and so on.
And it made this enormous
difference in actual adoption.
So for me, that cemented the
lesson for forever, right?
Measure the user experience,
even though it's painful,
even though it's going to take
a bunch of big engineering
projects, because you will never
build your app the same way
again, and you will get a
much better user adoption
as a result of doing it--
much more impactful than any
feature that we
could have launched.
And yes, it's hard, right?
So the engineering
team will also
have to go through the
five stages of grief
in dealing with the
fact that in addition
to writing all the
features, they also
need to write the things
that let you measure
what the users are seeing.
But persist.
Metric number
two-- tail latency.
All right.
Sounds incredibly
boring, unless you're
in reliability, in which
case we live for this stuff.
But let's run with boring
for right now, right?
So a quick survey of
the room-- hands up
if you think roughly you know
how reliable your service is.
Ah, see, I gave
way too much away.
The only people who
are raising their hands
are the ones who clearly do not
know [LAUGHS] because they're
in my team and they already
know what this drill is, right?
So yes, we just talked
about the importance
of actually measuring the
user experience the way
the users experience it.
But if you do that,
then clearly you
know how often the
user gets an error.
And therefore, you know how
often your user considers
your service to be available.
If that describes you and your
perspective on your service
right now, this will come as
something of a disappointment.
So users typically treat a
sufficiently slow response
as the same thing as
an error, and they'll
do one of two things.
They'll hit refresh if they're
kind and otherwise think highly
of your app.
Or they'll switch
to a different app,
and maybe they'll
come back to yours.
But certainly they won't
have a good experience,
and it will be the
same for them as
if they had gotten an error,
except the error at least is
sort of a polite prompt that
says you should hit Refresh,
whereas no answer is impolite
and tells you to you your time.
And so I think of availability
as being the above formula.
Availability is 100% minus all
of the errors that you return
and also minus all of the
slow responses you give.
And if you picture
this for yourself--
suppose you use a nice, snappy,
modern web-based application
or mobile-based application--
we offer a few of
them ourselves.
And on average you make a
query, and within half a second
the thing responds and
actually gives you the answer
or does the transition
or whatever.
Fine.
That's great.
So suppose one time
in 30, whatever
it was that it was
doing to process that,
fails somewhere
internally in your stack,
and so eventually your
time-outs kick in,
and you assume-- you
retry the query for them,
as opposed to making
them hit Refresh
because that's barbaric.
So you refresh after 10
seconds, and it retries.
OK.
So your availability
metrics there
will say that it's 99.9%
something available,
because that's how many
errors you're serving.
Your users will
say it's about 97%
available, which is for a
mobile app not terrible,
but it's not great, right?
Most of the mobile
apps that I use
are probably on the
order of 99% available,
and I can definitely
notice as a user
the difference between
let's say 99.5%
and 97%, which is
what I have here.
You'd have a completely
different view
of what the user
experience is just
by changing the way that
you consider availability.
And so then the
question, of course,
becomes well, how much
slower than median
does the thing have to
be before the user will
consider it to be an error?
I don't have a
generic answer for you
because it depends
a lot on your app.
If you're using an
app like Mail and it
takes a few extra seconds
for a mail to be received,
you don't even notice.
If it takes a few
extra seconds for you
to hit send before the mail
is registered as being sent,
you notice that, right?
And if you click on a mail
and the mail doesn't snap up
instantly, you're going
to try it yourself
in a couple of seconds,
so maybe factor of four.
But you can probably see
this, and if you can't, you
should figure it out.
Again, back to measuring
the user experience,
because you want to know at what
point your user thinks your app
isn't working correctly.
And if you don't know
that, well, your users do,
and you won't change
your app appropriately,
and then you'll have less
adoption and eventually
catastrophe.
So if you want a rule of thumb,
something to walk away with,
5x.
5x is a pretty
good rule of thumb
for many interactive
applications
that I see people using.
And it's not complicated
at that point, right?
You can measure what
your median latency is.
Just consider anything that's
more than five times as
slow as your median latency
to be an error, and again--
five stages of grief, followed
by then you'll actually
spend some time and try to
figure out really is it 5x,
or is it more like 8x?
I encourage you not to be
overly optimistic because again,
eventually the users will
make their own choice
about your application.
You'd really like to
know what they're seeing
and how they're
behaving, and you'd
like to have the
opportunity to tune your app
to deal with that.
But figure out what latency
starts to cause people to retry
or starts to cause them
to switch off your app
and do something different
for a while and come back,
and tune yourself so that your
tail latency is below that.
And tune your metrics
so that once you
hit that tail latency that
causes them to switch behavior,
you consider it an
error, and then you
can decide how available
you want your app to be.
But that is actually measuring
the user's experience
of availability and not
your server's experience
of availability.
And if you haven't measured the
sort of tail latency before,
like I said, just
five stages of grief.
Let it happen, right?
You'll get through it.
But don't stay in denial.
So topic number three then
is service efficiency.
And this could mean a
lot of different things,
but it is the place that I
see the most applications get
tripped up on, so
I wanted to spend
a bit of time talking about it.
So let's talk about
capacity planning.
It is as boring and dry a
topic as you could possibly
imagine for most developers--
pretty much almost
all developers,
I think, unless you're
actually charged
with making sure the
app works, in which case
it is near and
dear to your heart.
So capacity planning is
essentially a simple thing.
You take demand,
which you typically
get from historical behavior.
You extrapolate it
forward through time.
You add in anything
that we call inorganic,
but basically if you're going
to change your application
to make the demand go up,
or issue two queries instead
of one, or whatever
you're going to do
that changes your demand
curve that you know
is going to happen,
you add it in there.
You divide that by
how many servers
it takes to actually
answer a query,
and there again, you can change
the server, blah blah blah.
But it's probably been
fairly constant over time.
So you divide that and it tells
you how many servers you need
or how many instances you
need or, if you happen
to be stuck on a cloud product
that makes you buy stuff
in advance to get a good
price, how many you're
going to have to purchase,
and you're done, right?
Easy peasy.
Well, see, no,
unfortunately, because there
is this extra bit, which is that
you're all either developers
in this room or you manage
developers for the most part.
All of you are doing things
to that binary that's
running on those servers.
And you're doing
things that change
the amount of time
that is required
for processing a given query.
And so even if you are
perfect at extrapolating
how many queries you're
going to be getting,
you're changing, if you
will, the denominator.
And sometimes you're not
changing it by a little bit.
It was not uncommon
for us to see
swings of 50% over
the course of a week
if you're not watching
it, because it's
easy to sort of add
things to the inner loop.
And it's easy to add a
feature that makes a call out
to something else
and blah blah blah.
And even small changes, like
configuration file changes,
can sometimes
dramatically change
the amount of compute
capacity that's
required to process a query.
And we call that service
efficiency overall, right?
How many CPU cycles,
disk spindle seeks,
network bytes, et
cetera, et cetera,
is required to answer a query or
to serve an interesting action
in your service.
And, like I said, easy to
change, basically invisible,
unless you do
performance testing
all the time, which
we'll get to in a second.
And one of the most frequent
flyers in the post-mortem that
follows inevitably
from this, because
of course what happens
with service efficiency
is none of you, presumably,
run your services
at the very hairy edge of
falling over all the time.
Everyone builds redundancy
into how they do provisioning.
Either it's redundancy to handle
peaks that happen to happen.
You're running a news service,
and something interesting
happens in the world.
You can use your own imagination
as to what that might be.
And demand spikes 30%.
Or you're running a
photo application,
and there's a concert, and so
within this one area within,
this one geographic
region, suddenly
the number of pictures people
are taking-- no, you don't even
need that, right?
Just wait for New Year's Eve,
and the number of pictures
that get taken on
these hourly spikes.
It's very odd,
right, goes way up.
So you have enough
redundancy to handle spikes
and also to handle a
certain amount of failure.
Service efficiency changes
eat into that capacity reserve
that you've got, but
they do it invisibly
because normally
you're provisioned
to have a bit of failure.
And if you don't have a
bit of failure happening
at the same time you have a
spike, everything runs great,
right?
And so the post-mortem
usually reads something like,
we thought we were
provisioned n plus 2 for peak,
but it turned out that
over the past two weeks,
our service efficiency had gone
down because reasons, which
could be like we
introduced a new CPU
type that we were using, or
somebody checked something in.
The list of reasons
is always different.
The result is always the same.
So it turned out
we were actually
provisioned only n plus 5,
and then one of our sites
had an outage, and
then cascade failure.
because once you're
out at a capacity,
unless you've done a very
careful job of designing
a distributed service to
do very good load shedding,
cascade failure all
the way through.
And then the only way to recover
from that is basically shut off
all the traffic, and then
bleed a little bit back in
to get the caches
warmed back up,
and eventually you can get back
to a stable operating model,
but it takes hours.
And your users notice.
Ask me how I know this.
[LAUGHTER]
So the best practice
here is-- again
sorry for creating more work,
but this is really important.
You've got to measure how
efficient your service actually
is at servicing queries.
And I don't actually think
that daily is too frequently.
Best practice, of
course, would be
we'll build a system that
actually measures it for me
and spits out a
report every night.
And then I'll
notice immediately.
It's much easier to
automate this sort of thing
and have a performance test.
And you don't have to test
every little edge case, right?
You just have to test the
things that are the big volume
drivers for your service.
But if you have it automated,
and you get this report
every night, you'll notice.
You'll also notice
other interesting things
like, hey, our service
efficiency is still the same,
but our latency has
been creeping up
a few milliseconds every week.
So we've gone from
having a service that
was nice and snappy to a
service that's kind of kludgy,
even on a good device, and
really bad on a bad device,
over the course of three
months without anything
dramatic happening.
And that's obviously something
else that can bite you.
It bites you mostly
in that your user
adoption seems to nose
over a bit more than you
would have hoped.
If you're running hypothetically
on a cloud provider that just
has flexible use and so
you can use more capacity,
you might not have a cascade
failure when your service
efficiency gets bad,
but what will happen
is your finance person will come
and find you a few weeks later,
and they'll say, huh, we got a
bill from our cloud provider,
and it's about 30% higher
than we had expected.
What's going on?
And then I would say
typically two or three
weeks of thrashing goes on.
You accuse of the cloud
provider of overbilling you.
The cloud provider does
their own diagnostic
and says it seems to
be running normally.
This is assuming you have
a cloud provider who lets
you flex in and out, right?
If you have one where you're
running on fixed instances,
then your service
just goes down,
which has the upside
of no extra bill
and sort of prompt
diagnosis, so I
guess there's pros
and cons to each side.
[LAUGHTER]
Personally I'd rather
have the finance
team yelling at me
than the sales team,
but you know that's me.
So to keep your
costs under control,
but more importantly to
keep your service stable,
you've got to know what
your service efficiency is.
And the way to know that--
because developers
will check stuff in,
that's what you pay them for--
the way to know that is
to actually benchmark it
quite regularly.
So that's actually it.
Like, if I trace most of
the big post-mortems where
things that were not sort
of obvious were happening,
I could put them into one
of those three categories.
And so if you measure
those three metrics
and go through
the work that it's
going to take to actually
measure them accurately,
not as an approximation, I
think you will find that A,
you service runs better, B,
you have fewer outages, and C,
you have a lot
more user adoption.
And most of us kind of like
those three properties.
So that is it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]